Thank you everyone for coming to our talks at Google event today with Tina
Sharkey.
It's great to have you,
Tina.
So psyched to be here.
And we brought Brian in the snack,
so if you're on the live stream,
we'll figure out how to get them to you later.
But anyone in the room,
feel free to get up,
get some snacks.
I won't feel insulted.
I'll be really happy actually.
So
Tina is the cofounder and CEO of brandless,
which is an ecommerce startup that's looking to shake things up in the industry
by offering high quality products at a really affordable price point.
Great to have you again.
It's awesome to be here.
Uh,
can you tell us a little bit about brandless in your own words?
So
brandless um,
my cofounder,
Ido Leffler and I,
um,
we were sort of feeling like modern consumption was just very,
very broken.
Um,
and that meant that if people really understood what things cost versus what
they pay for them,
um,
they'd be in his words like riding in the streets.
Um,
I don't know that I thought people would be riding in the streets but that there
was this,
this perception that better had to cost more and it actually really doesn't and
so when we found him brandless we were really trying to act like this very high
level,
try and make sense of consumption.
There was a sense that there were the haves and the haves nots and that people
couldn't actually find what they were looking for.
Shop the values they believed in,
whether it was their dietary values like I'm gluten free or I'm kosher or Vegan
or I like to eat organic or it was their belief systems.
I don't want animal testing,
I want non GMO,
I'm,
I want certain foods,
certain things that I reached for every day to sort of live up to my value
system.
If in fact they were to use that as their shopping filter,
they would definitely be paying a premium for everything because their value
system actually comes at a premium but it doesn't have to.
And so at brandless at the highest level,
we're trying to democratize access to goodness,
starting with everyday essentials,
which is everything on brandless is $3,
sometimes it's two or three or three for three.
And all of our food is non-gmo.
Most of it is organic,
tons of it as gluten free.
And all of our beauty and our personal care or shaving gel,
our shampoo or conditioner are,
I'm hand pains,
et Cetera,
are all completely clean.
Which means in the case of beauty and personal care,
it's free of animal testing.
It's free of SLS is a phosphate of sole face of,
of synthetic dyes,
et cetera.
And every single category that we develop at brandless,
we use that filter to say what really matters in that particular category.
So for example,
when we do cleaning,
um,
our cleaning products like our multi surface cleaner,
our toilet bowl cleaner,
um,
they are EPA safer choice certified.
Um,
everything that we do is just $3 or two for three or three for three.
But everything is very much created for what we consider the modern lifestyle.
How do you set yourself apart from other ecommerce startups that have been
coming up over the last few years?
For example,
the honest company,
which I think is doing similar,
uh,
non GMO healthy products.
So as a startup,
you know,
first and foremost we're a community and we're a community of people who believe
that everyone deserves better.
Um,
I can't really say what honest is doing because I don't know a ton about that
company other than to say that the pricing structure at brainless,
um,
everything that we sell is brand tax free.
So what we mean by that is we have eliminated all the inefficiencies in the
system for what things cost to produce versus what you're paying for them.
And so I don't know how honest does that by being a community that goes directly
to the consumers and makes things for the people that we serve,
we are developing the products.
Um,
we're putting them into our distribution centers and we're sending them directly
to you.
And so if you were looking at national brands that have the same quality as
ours,
organic coconut oil,
organic olive oils,
organic feminine hygiene,
um,
all the non GMO food on average,
you're saving 40% of brand tax savings of national brands of similar quality
when it comes to things like clean beauty,
clean personal care and clean,
um,
hygiene,
it's as high as 300 to 400% savings.
So I can't tell you what honest his system is and how they do that,
but ours is really about a community that is connected around a higher purpose,
which is that,
you know,
the doing is what matters in life.
When you check out at brandless,
um,
there's something extra in your shopping cart and that's a meal that we
partnered with feeding America to buy 'em on your behalf and in your honor to
feed those who don't have $3,
if you're a member of the more,
which is our membership.
And I'll talk about that a little later because there's a surprise coming for
all of you.
Um,
will donate 10 meals in your honor and every time you shop we donate two meals.
If you're a member in the first 18 weeks of being in service,
uh,
we've already donated over 150,000 meals to feeding America both to be deployed
to the disaster relief zones in California and Texas and Florida and Puerto Rico
where we don't ship,
but we still are trying to do what we can,
um,
as well as to the people facing hunger in this country,
in everyday systems all over the nation.
You mentioned the brand tax,
but maybe a few of us here are familiar with that term.
Could you tell us a little bit about that?
Yes.
You wouldn't be familiar with it because we made it up and we trademarked it.
Uh,
but we were trying to find a way to actually describe to people like what we
meant by that inefficiency in the system.
So when you think about the cost of less per se in our organic tomato sauce is
as an example.
So we make three different kinds of tomato sauces,
[inaudible],
garlic and tomato and basil.
They're all organic.
Um,
and we work with our partner to do that.
At that point,
we then send them to our distribution center and we send them to you.
That's not how most other tomato sauce is distributed.
It's often created at that manufacturers.
Sometimes the brand owns the manufacturer.
Sometimes they partner with somebody who's making it for them.
They then have to distribute it,
so sometimes,
especially in the organics and naturals market,
you can't sell directly to a store like a whole foods.
You have to go through a distributor and then that distributor takes a
percentage.
Then you sell it,
let's say to whole foods and it's,
let's say it's a special tomato sauce that you want to have on a special shelf.
Okay,
well then whole foods gets their markup and that shelf has a special cost.
Let's say there's already a sauce on that shelf.
Well,
you have to then remove that sauce potentially and put your sauce.
Let's say you want to do an end cap,
which is like at the end of the aisle,
sometimes you see those specials or you have somebody out there sampling the
sauce for you.
The point is that all of those touches,
and there's many,
many,
many more,
you end up paying for that,
which is all on top of the cost of the sauce to begin with.
So if a time that sauce leaves the manufacturer and ends up on your pasta,
it could be,
you know,
two,
three,
four times of what it actually costs to make.
I mean,
everything is different,
but if you're benchmarking it against a brand,
like an organic of similar quality and you're going to see on average those
types of savings.
So we roll that into this idea of brand tax free,
which is to say that we're trying and every which way that we can to eliminate
that middleman.
Every product is different because most products are sold differently,
you know,
so the way a tomato sauce gets distributed might not be the same way.
You know,
we also sell plates and bowls and cups and knives and things like that.
So every system is different.
But in general,
wherever we can be completely efficient and pass on whatever our,
you know,
costs are to you by offering everything at one simple $3 price.
I think something that characterizes Googlers,
even though we work at a big company is that we're pretty entrepreneurial in
nature and people are always thinking about what kind of product they could
potentially go out and start making or what kind of startup they'll go and
found.
Um,
so maybe could you tell us a little bit about your journey that led you to come
up with the idea for brandless and how your previous work experience influenced
your decision to start this company in particular?
Yeah,
well I would say that,
um,
first of all,
the only reason I was even keen to start another company because I didn't think
I was going to do that.
Um,
I sort of liken being an entrepreneur,
especially as a woman to like childbirth.
If you remembered what it felt like,
you wouldn't do it again.
Um,
so somehow there's some gene in your brain that helps you forget that because I
do have two awesome sons.
So clearly that didn't happen to me.
And I think entrepreneurship and startups are very similar.
Um,
which is that it's a birth process and it's hard.
and it's unpredictable,
but it's completely awesome.
Um,
I decided that if I was going to do another one,
um,
that I was going to do it with the first and foremost with the people I wanted
to be on that journey with.
And so my extraordinary cofounder,
Ido Leffler with somebody that I wanted to change the world with from a business
and scale and perspective.
And so we had been friends for like many years before we,
we lived in the same town.
Our families were friends.
I was at the hospital when his daughter was born,
like just really somebody I admired and I admired his career.
And he built a bunch of CPG companies that had not just great success,
but also had purpose and meaning.
And everything that I try and do in my life is rooted in sole purpose and
meaning.
So I said,
I'm going to start a company with this person and it's going to be for profit
and for purpose.
And we're not going to do purpose as a campaign.
We're not going to do purpose as something that's like a caboose that we're
going to like jack onto the back of it when it's giving Tuesday,
which it happens to be today.
I think giving Tuesdays amazing.
But I think every day should be giving Tuesday.
And that that's just a new way of thinking about the way we actually can live
our lives.
And so that journey started with the right cofounder.
The second thing was as my tour of duty as a venture capitalist,
you know,
everyone in here I'm sure in some way,
and you're a product manager.
I've been a product manager is about building things.
There's features.
So many of you may be working on features.
I've worked on many,
some of those features.
You know,
if you go through YC or you have one of these other incubation opportunities,
those features may be become products.
Um,
if that product actually has a life,
that product could get funding potentially and could become a company.
Um,
so of those companies that go from feature to product and company,
the rare exception get to be brands meaning something that people understand.
They,
they,
it means something more than any individual product that they ship.
Um,
very few of those brands actually have the opportunity to be category leaders.
So we're disrupting a category.
We want to be leader or even better,
are we going to create a new category?
So in the case of an Airbnb or a homeaway that was like,
wow,
it's alternative category to the travel category,
we're going to create a new one.
I would say Uber and Lyft and those companies all fall in that category to the
highest order.
If you get from feature to a product to company,
to brand to category leader would be a movement that actually not only you
creating a new category,
but you're inciting something that's bigger than your entire company.
Um,
that's actually about something that's about people and moving them and moving
society and culture to a place that you want to see and that your company
becomes one of the people in that movement.
But not necessarily the only person in that or the only thing in that movement,
that ladder,
like as an investor,
I was always looking for things that actually I felt could pass through.
I wasn't interested in investing in features or even products.
And if it didn't have the potential to be a brand or a category leader,
it didn't feel like something that was sort of worthy of really venture capital,
which is what it's there for cause it's the longterm play.
Um,
so when Edo and I landed on this idea,
um,
I felt like in my soul this was a movement,
this was something that was bigger than any individual piece of its parts.
Uh,
which leads to the idea of like brandless like are we generic?
Are we not a brand?
No,
we are unapologetically a brand.
Like,
but we're redefining what it means to be one.
And we're saying we're a brand that's based on truth.
That's based on authenticity and that's based on being in direct collaboration
with the people that we serve.
So I would say that when Google and Larry and Sergei founded this company,
it was the idea of democratizing information and that's like a big lofty goal
and like mission accomplished extraordinary for us.
Um,
but they're not the only ones doing it,
but you guys are clearly the category leaders in a category that didn't even
exist or maybe it did,
but it was like very,
very early.
Um,
at brandless we're trying to democratize goodness.
and that's like this movement,
this idea that everyone deserves better and better,
shouldn't cost more.
Like that's just not fair.
But it's a very hard thing to get your brain around when somebody tells you that
this premium that you've been paying,
you don't need to pay.
And this isn't about going wholesale.
We're actually engineering everything from the ground up,
but we're in direct relationship with the people that we serve.
And so in doing that and being a community first,
we think about every single person that we have the privilege of working with.
Um,
they're members of our community.
And so the love letters,
the notes,
the engagement that we get back all the time,
like every minute coming into our slack channels are and all of our social
channels,
they can't believe that like they're in conversation with the company that
they're buying organic tomato sauce from or organic feminine hygiene from or
clean beauty from or other things like that.
Because our attitude is if you want to be DTC direct to consumer,
then you have to be PTP,
which is person to person.
And so everybody that comes into our community,
we consider a member of our community and everyone that's not in our community,
we see as an awesome stranger that we have best intentions to hopefully bring
them along our movement.
What do you see as being your biggest success of the first few months?
Cause you guys just launched in the summer,
right?
Yeah.
Um Hm.
We're still here.
Uh,
so the biggest success,
um,
I would say that like 60 hours after our launch,
uh,
we got this incredible number back.
Um,
and that number was 48,
and that number has held every single day since then.
Um,
what does that mean?
It means that we shipped a 48 states every day and we weren't targeting 48
states.
We weren't advertising to 48 states.
Uh,
we would like to shift to 50,
but we can only ship in the contiguous us right now.
That's why Puerto Rico gets our efforts,
but doesn't get our product yet.
Um,
and Alaska and Hawaii are not happy with us,
but we're trying,
the Canadians we really love,
but we keep asking them to make friends with people in Detroit or Seattle that
have like a large minivan because I just can't get it to Canada right now.
Um,
but the point is that that success,
the idea that the people that we built this for found it,
whether they were in Tallahassee or Tennessee or parts of Texas,
like they found it and the notes that we get back,
people who have affordable luxuries and could choose to get and shop anywhere,
but don't have access.
People that never thought they could have access because they can never afford
organics for their family.
People that have dietary restrictions,
it didn't know where to get these things and now can find them at affordable
prices and people who are shifting their behaviors.
For example,
we sell tree free toilet paper,
which means that no trees were cut down or we to make toilet tissue.
It's made from bamboo grasses and sugar cane.
Um,
and so that are just things that people love.
They didn't know that they could actually shop their values at affordable
prices.
They didn't have access to things.
And so some of the communities that have shown up early,
um,
like the gluten free community is a very active community online.
Um,
and so they found us,
um,
and that was exciting.
The vegan community,
they found us like our,
I think it was like our first week we had gluten free Brownie mix,
gluten free.
I'm a pancake mix and gluten free blueberry muffin mix,
uh,
before we did any of the rest,
like the regular pancake or whatever.
And they sold out like in three days.
And we were so surprised like what just happened.
And then we learned that like one of the gluten free,
like very active online,
uh,
groups found brandless and boom,
we sold out.
I mean we're back in stock and we just didn't know that those were going to be
like interested in gateways or for example,
our first um,
skew of toothpaste is fluoride free.
So we thought,
you know what,
there is a growing community of people who believe that there shouldn't be
Florida and their toothpaste.
Um,
and so we know that is a niche community,
but it's an important and growing one and one that's very vocal,
believe it or not.
And so we launched a fluoride free toothpaste.
Well what do you know?
People like it blew up and they were using that as a doorway in to like the
entire assortment if Brown,
which has that intention,
every single bag box or bottle.
So they're just some early insights.
Cause you know,
we're only,
I don't know,
18,
20 weeks in,
but those are some of the fun,
um,
nuances and stories that were starting to learn every day.
Yeah.
That brings me to the general question of how you think about the specific
products that you pick.
Because personally,
a lot of my friends who are really excited about a brand lists,
it's because they're vegan and they're just so excited that it's so easy for
them to access a wide variety of Vegan products at a pretty affordable price
when usually I think vegan products either tend to be really hard to find or
they tend to be expensive relative to other products.
So this is a really good venue for them to reach out to and have easy access to
what they need.
So how do you think about that?
Because I know you also have organic,
a feminine hygiene products and office supplies,
so it's a wide range of things,
but it seems like it's very thought through.
Yeah.
So what's really interesting on when you go to buy shoes,
whether you buy them online or whether you buy them in a shop,
the likelihood is you're probably just going and you're buying the shoes and
you're done.
Whether it's a checkout at an online store or whether it's a physical store.
And maybe if you're buying them from an online store and you don't know your
size and they have a good return policy,
maybe you're buying two sizes and you're returning one.
That's a possibility.
It's very different than the consumables business in the consumables business.
It's about the mission and the trip.
So what does that mean?
That means that these are the things that you reach for every day,
whether you reach for them in your Pantry,
whether you reach for them under your sink,
whether you reach for them in your lunch room,
where your bathroom or even your purse,
um,
they're the things that you consume every day.
They're the things that you replenish all the time.
And so when we created this,
um,
initial assortment of products,
we're really intentional in saying,
okay,
what do people buy 52 weeks a year and how many households in America?
We took a very analytical approach.
How many households in America by that product?
Like what's the,
what we call AHPs the household penetrations.
And then we studied that based on every single thing that people buy and how
could we make sure that unlike shoes,
which is what I would call a one and done,
right,
these are like the baskets that people are building.
How can we make sure that our shelves are stocked with just what mattered where
we were creating selection and assortment and where there was,
what we call expandable consumption.
So in the case of stacks,
for example,
snacks is something that 98.8% of American households by,
um,
and they buy them 52 weeks a year.
And if I was to ship you a box of 10 different kinds of snacks,
whether or not you would eat those snacks,
um,
you might try them.
If you didn't want to try them for whatever reason,
you might bring them to work.
You might bring them to the soccer game.
You might host a,
you know,
Monday night football party.
Like there's lots of different ways that you might eat that snack.
Um,
so that's a place where we're launching,
you know,
Jalapeno Cheddar,
keenwah puffs along with,
you know,
olive oil and sea salt popcorn.
Um,
all of these are non GMO,
some of these organic and we're launching keen watch chips alongside of tomato,
tomato and basil like homeless puffs,
you know,
all kinds of yummy things.
Um,
and they're all,
some of them are here.
Um,
and so we're trying new things.
We're experimenting with new things.
There are other places where you don't need to be paralyzed by 50 feet of salad
dressing,
um,
when the truth is you probably just use one,
two or three.
And so in that particular case,
our organic Italian dressing,
our organic balsamic vinegar dressing and organic poppy seed dressing,
um,
are the three that we know are the most popular.
And then we introduced one,
um,
that we're crazy about.
And that's a,
um,
it's a ginger,
a dressing that may not be everyone's taste,
but it's a way to try new things.
And so in that category,
we're doing just what matters.
In the case of oils and vinegars,
we launched an organic,
extra virgin olive oil and an organic balsamic vinegar.
Might we do other ones?
We might,
but we knew that was like the most important thing to do.
In the case of the holidays,
I'm starting in October and take you all the way through the year.
We have a maple,
a collection.
So that maple collection is what we call lto limited time offer.
And so we have the most incredible maple twist,
highly recommended maple cookies,
even maple lip balm,
maple coffees,
um,
and maple syrup.
The Maple Syrup is organic.
Um,
it's amazing and it's $3.
Good housekeeping just said it was,
they're like number one or number two pick for stocking stuffers,
um,
as like the best gift of the year,
uh,
to beautiful bottle,
et cetera.
So like looking at every single item with that lens of just what matters.
Not to do the over proliferation of choice,
but create choice where we know that you actually want choice and you want trial
versus in an area where you're locked into one thing or two things that we don't
need to create waste,
um,
don't create waste there.
So we're very intentional by product,
by category and by skew,
how we create them,
what the formulations are and how we live up to our own sort of filter of just
what matters.
Is there some sort of feedback cycle with what customers want?
Do you ever get,
oh my gosh,
yes.
Um,
so the initial assortment when we launched,
we launched with about 114 what we call sk use,
uh,
you know,
items.
And now we're probably north of 200.
We're probably around two 20,
but everything,
since our launch has been based on the feedback of things that people were
looking for.
So there was very much high request for 'em oatmeal's.
Um,
and so we launched oatmeal in a September organic oatmeal's.
We launched them in packs and we launched them in flavors.
There was a big request for,
um,
soups.
So we just launched our organic chicken broth or vegetable broth and beef broth.
What I love about our soups as an example,
um,
you know how you can buy in the store,
those cartons of soup.
Um,
the thing I hate about those is if I'm not cooking for my kids,
I opened one and then I feel like I'm wasting it because if I don't use the
whole cart and I have to throw it away,
what's great about this is for $3,
you actually get three,
um,
individual sizes so you can just open them,
uh,
for what you need.
Um,
we also launched m two for three of a Vegan and organic.
We have a tomato soup,
we have a butternut squash soup.
You have a red pepper soup.
Um,
they're awesome and they come in these little individual boxes.
So we're very intentional about that.
And people really wanted soup,
but we needed to do soup the [inaudible] way.
And so if we can do it the brandless way where we can be brand tax fee and we
can lend it at a price that makes sense and it lives up to our own values and we
love the partner who can scale with us,
we're good.
Um,
but all of that feedback that we're getting for our future assortments,
we're cocreating with our community.
What has been one of the biggest challenges that you faced since starting out?
Um,
I would say that,
you know,
in the context of talking to the Google audience,
both here and in the stream,
and I'm sure this will live on youtube thereafter,
is that we,
in being not a feature or a product or a brand or a company or a category
leader,
but a movement,
we really need to get big,
fast.
And so I would say that scaling the company and the team,
because at brandless,
like we put people first and that starts with every single person who works at
brandless.
And so growing our team and growing it quickly,
but with the right people and the right filter.
You know,
I say that when I look at my own algorithm for recruiting,
like I totally wasted the Geo at the awesome human,
like I don't care.
Uh,
yes,
of course it needs to be qualified,
but qualifications do not Trump an awesome human factor.
And so finding the right people who not only have the skills and the confidence
and the scale to want to be part of a startup,
but also understand scale or how to get to scale and they're excited about going
to scale,
but they believe that the doing in life is really what matters.
And they want to make a difference not only by day and what their shipping and
deploying,
but in the company that we're building,
which we believe is gonna,
you know,
change the way people think about things and really try and just keep focusing
on the idea that everyone deserves better.
And that we can actually democratized goodness,
uh,
with every shipment,
with every box,
with every post,
with every tweet.
Um,
and with all of our intentions.
So with brandless you kind of exists at this intersection between commerce and
then also technology.
Do you ever feel like there's a conflict of interest between the two sides and
how do you decide which side to give into any one point?
I would say that there's a very good chance that might happen in the future,
but because we barely have deployed like version one,
I would say we're in an MVP plus right now.
So we haven't hit that place where those two are in conflict.
But,
uh,
we definitely want to give people the runway to pursue their passions and to
pursue their interests.
And so the more data that we can play with,
the more people are enabled to use that data,
um,
to tell the kind of stories that are going to help them move their piece and the
larger piece of brandless forward.
So I'd say that we're all sort of data scientists underneath it all.
Um,
you know,
some of us have the skills and some of us have the desire to sort of understand
those insights.
So triangulating between like who are our shoppers and how are they part of our
community,
what are in their baskets so that we can give them more of those things and how
can we deploy the features and functionality and to make that automagically
possible for them,
um,
uh,
in a mobile environment,
um,
so that we can make it just super easy and mitigate,
click fatigue,
mitigate,
you know,
scroll fatigue,
um,
and get them in and out really fast.
So,
you know,
the smaller the screens get as,
all too well,
you know,
the harder it is to kind of get all those features into one scroll.
And so,
given that the universe is mobile first,
um,
how do you think about that in a non APP world?
Because we weren't interested in our first deployment of building an APP because
I didn't want to put a download in someone in front of someone who hadn't met us
yet,
but that will come over time.
So thinking about that balance between,
you know,
the roadmap,
the features and functionality,
and always,
always,
always putting people first.
And so that means both letting the employees,
um,
kind of scratched their data and curiosity itches and,
and,
and try things as well as the users who we want to make it as simple and fluid
and easiest possible.
In terms of features and functionality,
you recently announced be more,
which is an annual membership program.
I think in my eyes I see it as being similar to Amazon prime.
So how would you say you set yourself apart from Amazon prime and how did you
decide to start implementing this annual membership model?
So I have to say that being compared to Amazon prime,
I take a complete form of flattery.
Um,
so,
uh,
you know,
we should have such problems.
More people have Amazon prime memberships,
then there are,
then they have land lines in America.
So,
um,
I think that would be awesome.
Um,
having said that,
we launched on seven 11,
which,
um,
I thought it was funny because it was seven 11.
Little did I know that it was like free slurpee day and Amazon Prime Day,
but somehow,
um,
we had already set the date and that was like it.
Um,
but it didn't seem to matter.
Having said that,
um,
like I said,
Brian,
this is building a community.
And so when we launched be more,
our goal with being more was to give people an opportunity to do more,
to get more and to give more.
And so for $36 a year,
which if you do the math and everyone in this room I know can,
um,
it's $3 a month and it's free shipping with any be more ordered,
no matter,
no shipping threshold.
And so in addition,
when you join,
we give 10 meals to um,
feeding America every time you check out.
Um,
there's two meals that are in your shopping cart that we provide priceless,
as priceless as part of your brand,
less experience.
Um,
and we're just trying to remove any of the friction to try and make it easy for
people to have access to brandless products,
um,
to be able to afford the things that they want and to be able to feel like
everyday is giving Tuesday and that they can actually give more,
share more and be more engaged over time,
be more,
will be a platform for partners,
um,
to actually be able to maybe share more.
So for example,
on,
um,
black Friday,
uh,
when everyone else was slashing prices,
we um,
you know,
gave away a meditation App and gave,
we let people sort of think about what is brandless life mean?
Because when we say brandless,
we're not generic,
we're not private label.
We're saying just live more and brand less.
Like don't let somebody else tell you like that you should be taller.
Um,
there,
your hair should be straighter,
that your teeth should look a certain way,
that you should shoot the ball a certain way.
Like we think you're already awesome and just be more,
be more if we already are.
Um,
and so brandless is really about empowering people to just sort of live their
best lives and not have to make a choice between what they want and what they
can afford because people shouldn't be forced to choose.
We have our microphone here and
so have you have a question,
raise your hand and we can get the mic to you.
What percent of your products do you have to take a loss on to get that $3 price
point?
And then as you s I don't know much about how the distribution process works,
but,
uh,
I assume you have a limited number of warehouses or I don't know if you can
contract through like other people's warehouses or how that works,
but as you grow,
can you bring the cost of those products below to actually make a profit or
whatever on those $3 products?
So,
um,
the thing that will blow your mind is that the answer is zero.
There's not a single product that we are underwriting.
I'm at brandless not one.
Um,
now having said that,
there's different margins on different products,
but because you're not,
it's not like shoes where it's a one and done,
you're buying a basket and because you are finding the things that you reach for
every day and so it's a blended margin for sure.
Um,
uh,
but there's not a single product that we are losing money on if that's the
question.
Um,
in terms of distribution centers,
um,
right now we have distribution centers in California and in the Midwest and that
enables us to sort of try and do,
you know,
two days or less wherever we serve in the continental us and we'll be definitely
scaling that,
um,
as we grow.
Um,
and so we're working with partners who can help us do that.
because we are in the consumables business.
It's not like you can just go to any place that's like also packing shirts,
shoes,
and um,
clearly I'm obsessed with shoes.
Um,
but it's a different kind of distribution when you're like packaging up grocery,
like items even in the non perishable space.
Uh,
but we definitely will be able to scale that.
We are not shipping directly from our manufacturers.
Uh,
because like I said,
nobody buys one item.
Um,
people buy baskets because when you go on brandless you'll see it's the things
that you reach for every day.
Um,
and usually a better version of that.
There's a question related to that in the dory.
Uh,
how do you select suppliers behind brandless products?
What fraction of the products come from small businesses versus large
corporations?
This Brantley's plan to source more products that are produced locally or at
least in the u s
so that's a fantastic question.
Uh,
we have very,
very strict and sophisticated sourcing policies and strategies because we never
want to be to the point of that small shop.
We never want to have our tomato sauce produced in someone's kitchen.
I'm not to suggest that the formulation can come from a fast fabulous recipe
there,
but we kind of want to be,
I wouldn't say the smallest customer but one of those because we want to be able
to expand and grow and we also make sure that the partners that we work with
live up to all of our standards.
So organics,
non GMO is et Cetera,
et cetera.
And then all of the certifications that we put on the label and tell you about
that product has passed through all of the Qa and um,
that they have to go through.
And I'm so all of the partners are very much put through that filter in that
standard.
In addition,
we try and source as much as we can here in the u s and I would say the majority
of the assortment is um,
is developed here.
But there are cases where,
for example,
our pasta is our organic pastas and our organic olive oils come from Italy.
Um,
and so,
you know,
we are sourcing outside of the u s but it is our desire to do as much as we can
here.
Hi.
Um,
so I,
I think I see a very strong value proposition there for users who actually have
restrictions.
Like my sister is Blues Alley,
he's allergic to gluten.
So like,
uh,
having that wide variety is really exciting.
Um,
so I'm thinking for the consumer who actually doesn't have a lot of restrictions
or who doesn't really necessarily care about whether something is gluten free,
non GMO,
um,
pound for pound,
how you actually cheaper than similar competitors.
Okay.
Pound for pound.
So it's fantastic question.
Uh,
which is yes,
for those affinity groups,
the gluten frees,
the vegans,
et cetera.
We have extraordinary products at very fair prices,
but also there's like not a single person in this country,
um,
that couldn't benefit from the on average 40% brand tax free savings,
on national brands of equal quality.
So our organic peanut butters are organic.
Um,
um,
oils are organic sauces.
Like if you're comparing those two organic products in,
um,
at a retail location,
you're paying on average 40 to sometimes 200% more.
So the quality is extraordinary.
Um,
and their savings across the board.
and you shouldn't have to pay more for that.
And one thing I failed to say,
and this is relevant to everyone in this room and everyone on the live stream.
Um,
but I know this is going to be on youtube for the public so I can't give away
the code,
but tomorrow when you get your perks email,
um,
we provided a special code for all Googlers to get 33% off of being more,
so that you can have it for your families and that you can always get brown,
listen your homes and that's for every Googler across the continental us.
So definitely please tell your lunch mates,
your cube mates,
people you see in the hallway,
people you see on campus and that your friends across the community like
brandless is only going to be a community if the community helps us build it.
So we really wanted you guys to be able to participate in that way.
Hi,
I was wondering if you can tell us,
and it's a non confidential information,
of course,
the most capital intensive part of your business
because we have over,
you know,
we'll have by the end of the year,
probably like 250 products and then we'll be growing to more,
um,
you know,
definitely securing the inventory,
um,
putting the inventory into our distribution centers and turning that,
is something that we're,
you know,
very,
very aware of,
but because sales are,
you know,
are gray,
then we're in the non perishable business,
but we're turning those things all the time.
Um,
but because we're a startup and we went from literally out hundred percent cold
start,
um,
we are doing everything from scratch,
so we're building everything for the first time.
So it's not like we're optimizing our website or our servers or our data or
anything.
We're creating it.
The other thing about Brian lists is that we are completely vertically
integrated,
meaning that from the label to the photography to the packaging to the,
you know,
everything that you see at brandless,
um,
whether it's on Facebook or on Pinterest or on our website or in,
you know,
any setting,
everything we create ourselves.
And so we're also a content company because we're creating all of this content
about how to use it,
how to share it,
recipes,
all of that.
And we're doing that all from scratch.
So there's an investment in building out the company and building out all of the
systems at all of the stories and all of those pieces and parts of,
um,
of making brandless um,
a community that you want to participate in.
Another question from the Dory.
How do you compete effectively with incumbents like P and g,
Unilever,
et Cetera,
and how do you overcome consumers' emotional attachment to love brands?
I love that question.
Um,
the question is really,
I'll take it in two parts.
The first question is how do we compete with Unilever and P and g or the,
let's call those the incumbents.
And the installed base.
We're not trying to pick compete with P and g and Unilever because they don't
have any direct to consumer relationships.
So those companies,
um,
their customers,
our stores or what we call channels.
So whether it's Amazon or virtual store,
digital store or a physical store,
they don't have any direct to consumer relationships.
So we're not really competing with them because we're building a community.
Um,
and they're really suppliers,
um,
to their channels.
Um,
in terms of the second part of that question is for the beloved brands,
this stat,
especially for those in the room might come as a big surprise to you,
which is that of the top hundred CPG brands in America last year,
90,
which by my math is 90%,
uh,
were in decline.
So the problem is that the millennial are perennial,
perennial meaning the mindset of that new consumer irrespective of their age,
um,
doesn't want to buy the brands they grew up with.
There's a loss of trust.
Um,
there's an openness to wanting to meet companies who actually people want to do
business with,
who believe are socially responsible,
who believe that they are listening and,
and living their values and that are transparent in the way in which they
operate.
So we're,
we imagining what those relationships can be and do,
you know,
there are people that you know,
love their toothpaste or love their toilet paper.
Um,
but when you think about the amount of toothpaste and toilet paper that is
consumed in this country every day,
it's a very,
very big country and everybody,
at least I hope everybody is using toilet tissue of some sort and brushing their
teeth at least once,
but recommended three times if you were to going to go to the American dental
association and look at their best practices.
So there's a lot of opportunity to build new relationships and men introduced
new products and new,
um,
and new ways of buying them.
Uh,
so obviously there's a ton that goes into starting a company from getting people
to fill all the jobs that need to get done to,
uh,
looking for funding.
Um,
and just setting yourself for a successful setting yourself up for a successful
launch.
Can you talk about like the,
uh,
the journey from like the day you had the idea to the day you actually launched?
Yeah.
Uh,
so the journey of,
uh,
you know,
incubation,
uh,
so ido and I met,
um,
we both were doing a different jobs.
I was running Sherpa foundry and I was a venture partner at Sherpa capital and
he was the founding CEO of Ubi,
uh,
the stationary supply company that gives back and cheeky the tabletop company,
um,
that makes,
you know,
dishes and plates and bowls.
I'm all sold at target and around the country and probably many other companies
that he was developing with his partners.
And we said,
we have to do something together.
So that was probably maybe like even two years before,
if not longer before we actually decided,
uh,
to start to think about what we could do together.
Um,
at the time that we sat down and said,
let's incubate this and let's brainstorm from the time that we actually launched
the company.
Um,
we probably incubated it for maybe a year or a year and a half before.
I'm a friend who was a venture capitalist,
said,
wait,
you're incubating something.
Um,
we would love to see that.
And this turned out to be,
you know,
a very sophisticated late stage and early stage investor,
Jeff Brody at red point.
And he said,
I want to seed fund this company because I know you and I believe in you and I
believe in what you're doing.
Um,
but even if I don't believe in what you're doing,
I believe in you.
And when you're funding a seed company,
it's really about investing in the people because you're going to learn and
pivot and do lots of things before you actually launch that company.
So once we secured the seed funding,
I knew that I had to transition out of my day job.
Um,
and so I replaced myself and said,
okay,
I'm going to be the CEO of the company because I was like the acting CEO and Ito
was the acting chairman,
but we were still doing,
excuse me,
all these other things and we hadn't made any commitments to like launching it
or we hadn't taken any capital yet.
Once we started to do that,
we said,
okay,
well what are the things that we have to learn and prove to your question of the
margin?
Um,
can we actually source these things at this price point?
Can we create a Ui and Ux for the packaging,
which had never really been done in CPG where everything that we do has the
attributes that matter and the way in which we label things and the way in which
we communicate the values and the attributes of every single product.
Um,
could we create a system that would scale once we felt like we could do that,
we started to recruit the right people,
um,
who actually had the world class expertise to join our team.
And then once we started to do that and we realize that we felt like we had a
runway,
they're like,
we saw the path to,
to,
to actually bringing this to market.
Then a red point said,
you know what,
we want to lead the series a.
And so once that happened I said,
okay,
I'm going to like shift and be the full time CEO,
raise that funding and then really begin to recruit the team.
But um,
up until that point,
even though we knew our name was brown lists,
we were operating under a code name,
uh,
which is a little known story actually.
Entrepreneur magazine I think wrote about that,
which was funny.
They thought that was really interesting,
which is that we operated under a phone name because we didn't want to tip our
hand to the industries that we might be disrupting.
And so all until we raised a series a,
we were operating under a phone name.
We had a foe,
linkedin,
we had a foe website,
we had full business cards for email addresses,
everything.
Um,
because we were in sort of supplier conversations to like make sure,
and we didn't want to sort of tip our hand to what we were actually doing.
A,
but then once we raised a series a,
then we came out as brandless.
Uh,
we relaunched the website,
not the commerce site,
but the sort of marketing side,
you know,
while we were building it.
Um,
and then we started recruiting the actual,
you know,
scale team engineering product,
merge,
everybody,
marketing,
et Cetera.
Um,
and we were off to the races.
We then knew that we were going to launch in July and we didn't really need to
raise yet.
Um,
but some folks had heard about our launch.
And so some of those folks are actually Google.
Um,
and NEA,
uh,
Google ventures,
not Google or alphabet.
Um,
so,
uh,
Google ventures in NEA came to us and said,
we're very excited about what you're doing and we know you're launching and like
three weeks or whatever.
It was very,
very tight.
And,
um,
but we really believe in it and we want to be a part of it.
And so we raised our series B,
um,
before we ever launched.
And in fact we announced the launch and the series being on the same day.
So,
um,
that was kinda crazy.
Um,
and then we launched on seven 11 on slurpee day and Amazon Prime Day.
Who knew
from the,
from the time you probably at the time the idea was conceptualized,
did the idea or your execution stayed on that same track or you had to pivot?
That's a great question.
No,
we actually like,
it's remarkable.
I haven't talked to 'em Edo.
Um,
but uh,
we stayed on the exact same track.
Um,
I haven't mentioned that to Edo recently that like can you believe that like our
first business plan,
like everything we thought we were going to do,
we did.
And in fact,
funny story was that we started,
um,
under embargo going to talk to the media around the march time frame for the
July launch,
which is really a long time to be under embargo.
And so we had this fun and we only had at the time,
like a PowerPoint with jpegs.
We didn't have all the,
I mean the products were being developed,
but we didn't have the products with us.
Um,
so we would go in and we would talk to these journalists,
many of whom we knew because you know,
we've been doing like,
you know,
I hadn't relationships from other companies,
whatever.
And you know,
when I would tell the story and we would tell them about these incredible
products,
they're organic,
they're non GMO,
they're this,
they're this.
And,
and then we'd wait like three,
two,
one,
they're all $3.
And at that moment,
then we would go silent and the journalists would all say to us,
like,
you gotta be kidding.
Get outta here.
Stop horsing around.
And Tada.
They were like,
stop wasting our time.
We're like,
no,
they're really all $3.
Like we swear.
In fact,
that's not true.
Some are two for three,
summer,
three for three.
And so once they kind of like process that idea,
um,
and then we got them the samples under embargo,
they were all like,
how quickly can I get it for myself because they loved it.
So then Ito called me up about two weeks before the launch and he said,
I'm mad at you.
And I said,
what do you mean you're mad at me?
He said,
we never recorded all of those meetings.
And like on July 12th,
everyone will know and we can't do that.
Like,
same story.
I said,
you know what,
it's not too late.
And so our creative director,
Jenn tank,
um,
and I said,
you know what,
we have two weeks.
So we put an ad in craigslist and we said,
we're looking for some actors to come to a food tasting at a startup in San
Francisco.
That's all we told them.
Um,
and the reason we wanted to actors was because we were on such a tight budget,
um,
that we were hoping that actors would more likely have like good expressions on
their faces if we tried this,
this PR thing.
But we didn't,
they didn't know what we were doing.
And we did the exact same thing except a little,
they actually got more than the journalists because they had more than jpegs.
We took the mentor generic conference room and we just put the food out just
like it's here.
Um,
and then they tasted it.
And then we walk them into this room.
And maybe we can put this on live stream.
I mean,
on the recorded thing.
Um,
the room next door to the conference room is what we call the brandless lab.
And it's kind of my version of the Willy Wonka chocolate room.
There's no chocolate river,
although maybe in a new real estate,
I can get that written into the deal.
My fantasy to have a chocolate river in the office.
But that's just me.
Um,
and so
we showed them everything and we said,
all these things that you've tasted,
that the DA,
it's all $3.
And we got the exact same reaction of the journalists.
Like,
what are you kidding me?
Stop it.
That's a possible,
that era.
And then we called that awesome strangers and that was the video that we
launched with,
which were these people coming in,
tasting and then seeing it and then having that reaction.
So in truth,
we didn't change it from the beginning.
Um,
but we tried to,
we found that consistently the reaction now maybe if the reaction hadn't been so
good we have changed it.
But,
um,
the team has done such an extraordinary job at creating products that people
really love.
Yeah.
Why $3?
That's a great question.
So I would say three reasons because we love threes.
Um,
so the first reason was that part of the brandless experience,
um,
and when you go and you check it out is that
all of us are completely paralyzed by what's called now the paradox of choice.
That there's like you go to the drug store,
you go to the supermarket and there's,
as I said before,
50 feet of salad dressing,
300 sauces to choose from.
It's like what?
Like how do I even choose?
So part of our,
our,
our opportunity with to simplify everything,
including the price.
Like what's the difference between two 89,
four 62 m six 21 for 32.
Like it's just,
what is that?
That's like a manipulation.
So simplifying,
it was one of our objectives being completely easy and transparent to navigate.
And the most important thing is that when we studied the organics and naturals
market,
um,
the sort of what we call better for you,
organic,
Vegan,
non GMO,
et Cetera,
that market,
if you look at that filter,
$3 is not the entry point into that market.
And so our goal was to like what we call blow the doors off the front of the
building and make it much more accessible to a much broader swath of people
because in our intention was that everyone deserves better and better than have
to cost more.
And so we were very deliberate.
So it was simplification,
it was ease and making a much broader addressable audience.
Okay.
Hi.
Thank you for being here.
First of all,
it seems like with the quality of the product and also the price point,
you're product is ideal for like a low income community.
Um,
do you have plans to,
I guess even with the,
well let me rephrase that.
It's great for the low income community.
However,
know that there's like digital divide in those communities as well.
So are there,
do you have plans for your company too?
I really penetrate this market and really reach these customers.
Absolutely.
So I love that question because,
um,
the thing that I was saying about,
and you said what were some early surprises because when we launched it,
we just sort of put it out there,
right?
We were like,
let's just see a,
if you build it,
they will come.
And they did.
And so we've been hearing from so many people across the country that either
were living in food deserts where they didn't have access to all,
you know,
organic,
non GMO is et Cetera,
or are they couldn't afford that for their family and for their first time
they're able to afford that and they're able to have access to it.
Um,
and the digital divide is not as bad as the food desert divide.
And so,
uh,
what we're finding is that the installed base of,
you know,
mobile phones and Wifi networks,
et Cetera,
it's much broader than the food.
Uh,
and,
and p deeply penetrated then access to quality organic and non GMO foods and
goods for families.
So we totally have plans,
but we're already executing on those plans.
But we're not done.
I mean,
we're going to go to every town.
We're going to drive,
you know what I call the United States of goodness tour and go out and really
meet people.
Uh,
what I would like to do when those communities is not so much offered them
brandless because they can get that today.
What I would like to do is meet the awesome strangers that live there and really
tell them that they deserve better and really tell them that they're already
awesome and they shouldn't have a sense that they're not,
or that they're less than because they're not less than.
And so if everyone starts to believe that they deserve better and that they're
already awesome and they can afford that,
maybe that will give them more confidence.
Maybe that will create a better conversation at the dinner table.
Maybe that will help people sleep better.
I mean,
we have nutritionals,
a men's Multivitamin,
a women's Multivitamin,
Melatonin,
antioxidants,
all $3,
like access to these things that they didn't have access to before because a pin
afford it.
B didn't have a store near them or see we're an educated about the values of
those types of products should be changing now.
Um,
but the most important thing,
the business that would like to be in is the confidence business.
Cause I don't care how you voted,
I don't care what your socioeconomic classes,
I don't care what your race,
your religion,
like any of that,
like you deserve better.
And if you strip away all those layers and all those targets and all the ways
that we have filtered ourselves as people,
we forgotten like what we're here for.
Like we're all the same.
And this country was built on that and this company was built on the idea that
everyone deserves it.
And it's not okay to have a divine whatever's happening in Washington.
Like we can change the system.
But by going into the system,
by building another system,
I mean that's what this company was built on and that's what our company is
built on.
We're just trying to change a different kind of system and trying to get back to
the values that we actually believe in as human beings.
Like we're in the human being business and all human beings were created
equally.
And this idea that people have to choose,
it's just not okay.
But that doesn't mean everybody has $3.
And so we want to help those people too.
And that's why we partnered with feeding America.
And that's why we're trying to,
people should teach people about tangible acts of kindness because if you just
make eye contact with a stranger,
like maybe that'll make their day better and if that makes their day better,
maybe they'll work harder or maybe there'll be kinder to their loved ones or
maybe their kids will feel more inspired and work harder.
Like who knows.
But I just think it starts with a smile from my perspective.
Thank you very much for coming here.
I really love the idea behind the brand list.
Thanks.
Sure.
Since you like threes,
I have three questions but they guidelines.
So the first one is about products.
Um,
I either send for a more expensive product,
like olive oil is what we discussed.
A three means low quantity and these potentially could mean,
you know,
like more ways for packaging and things like that.
Do you have plans to move like,
I don't know,
like $13 packages or something so that you can get much more,
uh,
you know,
like a paper on this or a olive oil or anything like that without more,
without,
with less damage to the environment.
And,
uh,
then,
the other two questions about the company.
Uh,
you said you were using phone,
uh,
for,
um,
names and emails and stuff.
Uh,
when did you,
uh,
trademark brand less and other related,
slogans and things like that so that you didn't dip off,
uh,
you know,
in Cubans and uh,
the third question is about the Capitol building the company.
Uh,
how much did you use off the shelf components?
you know,
sees them,
like putting things in the cloud and things like that to reduce cost on that.
Since you are building everything from Scott,
thank you very much.
So I'm going to try a,
those are three very unrelated questions.
So I'm going to see how fast file my brain is and the ability to answer those.
The first question is about how we thought about limited waste in our packaging.
And the answer to that is unequivocably yes.
Um,
you know,
you have to remember that we're only sort of 20 weeks old,
but we are working to create the most efficient,
just what matters packaging and sizing.
Um,
whenever we can.
I'm so you'd be surprised,
but it's like the little things.
For example,
um,
I remember Rachel who's,
our head merchant and I were talking about Ahmond's.
I'm sometime in,
I don't know,
February or March.
Um,
and not only did she source and create this incredible assortment of nuts and
mixes and all of that,
but the almond bad that you buy,
um,
it's resealable.
And so what I love about that is that you don't have to eat all of them at once,
but you don't have to like clip it or throw it away or serve it.
You can actually reseal the bag.
So it's not just about the size,
it's about being very intentional in trying to make your packaging work as hard
as it can for you.
That's the first thing.
The second thing is about,
um,
you asked,
we first you asked about the packaging.
I know the third question was about the deployment of the capitol.
Oh,
about when we Mark Brown lists.
So this is a funny story too,
which is that we trademark brand lists like way before we ever,
um,
just when,
even probably before the seed and when we were just incubated the idea and all
of our NDAs people that were working with us,
both suppliers as well as potential recruits sign these NDAs.
And in the NDA it said the name brandless and not a single person actually
noticed,
which I think is funny because we said that the operating name of the company
was Dosey.
Um,
but in the NDA that his people had to sign,
it said brandless in the fine print.
And nobody ever said anything,
which we just were waiting.
Cause I remember having a conversation with the lawyers know we can't put Brevis
and the NDA.
We can't disclose.
And it turned out that we had to,
because it was a real company that you were in a,
you know,
in nondisclosure with and nobody ever saw it.
And the third question was about the use of proceeds and how we broke down the
budget and what we're using for cloud computing versus,
I didn't get that last part off the shelf components.
So,
um,
so that's a fantastic question too because you know,
we could have probably launched earlier if we had gone with like,
you know,
a Shopify or some sort of a,
a turnkey,
but we really felt that in order to build the kind of community,
uh,
where we really owned all of our data and that that data belong to our ability
to be able to create the most remarkable experiences.
And that even if we were sort of MVP,
it was better to be MVP and to have the kind of,
um,
own solutions on the,
excuse me,
core,
um,
the core data and architecture of what we were building.
And then when it came to like,
you know,
ESPs and other places around,
emails scaling and you know,
other things like that,
uh,
that we can work with third parties and we didn't have to build those things
ourselves.
But when it came to things that were like core to the experience,
those we felt we really needed to own.
And so we made the decision build by license on sort of every aperture and we
continue to do that.
What about on the product side,
off the shelf products that then you brand us brand lists.
Do you do any of that as well?
Um,
well there,
there is no such thing as an off the shelf product.
I would say that in the case of what is a proprietary formulation,
um,
when it comes to organic brown sugar,
organic flour,
organic sugar,
organic Oregano,
like there's not a lot of formulation that's happening there.
It's so it's like the packaging and the just what matters when it comes to sort
of,
you know,
are things where we are a cocreating and co formulating with our partners.
You know,
we look at everything.
Um,
you know,
on a,
a case by case basis.
Great.
Well thank you everyone for coming.
It was great to have you tank.